Mark Twain declared Hawaii to be the loveliest fleet of islands...
...that lies anchored in any ocean...
...and not even years of mass tourism have managed to prove him wrong.
Its very name conjures up dreamy images of drinking mai tais to slack-key guitar,...
...attracting millions of visitors a year to these picture-perfect tropical islands.
Holiday makers crowd onto the sand here to enjoy some kitsch tourist action.
Don't miss a chance to catch an outrigger canoe race.
The Koa canoes have been part of the Pacific island life...
...and culture for 4,000 years.
Visitors can even try it out themselves.
Surfers love Hawaii.
Best breaks are along Oahu's north shore...
...especially at the Banzai Pipeline and Tunnels Beach.
Behind the natural beauty here, there's a simmering independence movement...
...working to break Hawaii from the United States.
The island's politics could be as rocky and as treacherous...
...as the Hawaii Volcano National Park.
The park itself is a striking combination of desolation and sulfuric lava.
It's best viewed from the safe distance of a helicopter.
"Aloha!" when you arrive, "Aloha!" when you leave.
It's all too easy.